Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
- Carlo! - Giorgio!
- Ce la faremo?
- Non lo so, Carlo: è difficile.
- Sì, è dura ma tu prova!
- Ci provo, vado?
Amici, siamo qui
in diretta Instagram e Facebook
per vivere, insieme a voi - anche YouTube!
Per vivere insieme a voi
quella che, a tutti gli effetti,
sembra essere davvero la fine del mondo.
Non come nel 2012,
secondo il calendario Maya,
invece dopo - ciccia.
Questa, se Dio vuole, è la volta buona!
- Giorgio, quanta gente
abbiamo collegata, adesso?
- Carlo, abbiamo cominciato
con quattro miliardi;
ma dopo l'ultimo terremoto,
mi sa che due miliardi
ce li siamo giocati.
- Guardate, guardate intorno a noi:
non è rimasto in piedi più niente,
è andato distrutto tutto, tutto!
Chissà quanta gente sta già pensando,
sfregandosi le mani, alla ricostruzione.
- Certo che questa fine del mondo
non ci sta facendo mancare proprio niente!
- Guarda, guardate, c'è pure un meteorite
in rotta di collisione con la Terra!
- Oddio, dove? - No, "Don't look up!".
- Vuol dire che sarà un "Deep Impact"?
- Sì, sarà un'autentica "Armageddon".
- Quindi "La morte viene dallo spazio"?
- Ma sarà "La notte della cometa"!
Oh, ma quanti film
hanno fatto sui meteoriti?
- Forse è già arrivato?
- No, è esplosa una centrale del gas!
- Un'altra? Questa sì
che è una vera tragedia!
Pensa alle bollette, adesso:
sarà da impazzire.
- E infatti, vedete?
La gente attorno a noi
sta letteralmente impazzendo!
Sembra una nuova pandemia: West Nile?
Vaiolo delle scimmie?
- No: dai sintomi, mi pare
la febbre del criceto.
- È vero, guardate:
la gente si sta riempiendo
le guance di cibo,
e gira continuamente intorno a una ruota.
Ma che ruota è? Quella di Napoli!
- 31: La fine del mondo
- 33: l'Apocalisse!
E 83: O maletiempo!
Infatti vedete, amici, che qui piove,
qui grandina, fa freddo;
e poi, improvvisamente,
un caldo eccezionale, siccità;
e poi, di nuovo alluvioni.
Cosa volete, amici?
Non ci sono più le mezze stagioni.
Qua non si sa più come vestirsi!
Guardate, guardate
che sta cadendo la luna.
Cadono le stelle!
Cade il Sole!
Cade la terra, tutti giù per terra!
Ma che fantastica diretta, amici:
se raggiungiamo il miliardo di likes,
domani la rifacciamo.
Come la rifacciamo?
Ma se è la fine del mondo!
Ma va: dietro ogni fine del mondo,
c'è sempre un nuovo mondo che inizia.
Davvero?
Sì, sta venendo avanti all'orizzonte!
Sì, sta marciando,
verso di noi, un esercito.
- Al passo d'oca?
- No. A passo di Gloria Gaynor.
- Ma questa musica non è Gloria Gaynor.
- Eh, lo so: ma se no,
YouTube ci bloccava.
Quanti stivaloni in latex.
E boa di piume, e glitter,
e parrucche e ciglia finte.
Ma Carlo, sarà uno stupendo futuro drag.
Sì!!
Amici, se vi piace questa fine del mondo,
e il suo nuovo inizio,
cliccate qui sotto e mettete un bel like!
Buonasera, buonasera a tutti.
(Applausi)
Be', come avete visto,
abbiamo cercato di concentrare
tutti i più triti e ritriti
luoghi comuni sull'Apocalisse.
Ne manca qualcuno?
Ve ne viene in mente qualcun altro?
Io, Io!
Eh, il film, quello che parla
della distruzione
di quella piantagione di the.
Quale?
ApocaLipton?
Apocalypto!
La fine del mondo Maya,
la sua distruzione
dopo l'arrivo degli spagnoli.
Che per quanto brutto,
visto quello che è successo,
è pur sempre stato
un nuovo inizio anche quello.
Vedete, amici, le sappiamo tutte.
E in quanto comici,
siamo degli esperti di apocalissi.
- Siamo degli apocalissologi
- Apocalissologhi.
- Apocalissologi - Apocalissologhi.
Non importa.
Siamo talmente esperti,
che quando TED ci ha invitato
a parlare qui sul palco
la prima cosa che abbiamo fatto è stata
- Hey Google, ma cosa
vuol dire Apokalypsis?
(Risate)
No, scherziamo.
Abbiamo subito risposto:
Grazie TED: per noi,
sarebbe davvero la fine del mondo.
Eh sì, perché vi sembrerà strano,
ma l'Apocalisse
è il nostro pane quotidiano,
è il pane di cui ci nutriamo
ogni giorno noi comici.
Dove c'è del disagio,
uno scontro generazionale,
dove ci sono abitudini sbagliate,
ipocrisie,
dove il nuovo spiazza il vecchio,
il comico si butta a pesce, e gioca,
con tutto ciò
che una vera apocalisse
dovrebbe spazzare via.
- Praticamente, siamo dei profeti.
- Praticamente sì, dai.
Perché se Apocalisse
è la fine di un mondo,
con i suoi valori,
le sue abitudini, le sue certezze,
noi ci siamo detti:
ma quante fini e quanti nuovi inizi
abbiamo messo in scena,
in 30 anni di spettacolo?
Tantissimi, ma tantissimi.
Tanto che a raccontarveli tutti,
adesso, ci vorrebbero - 30 anni.
Avete tempo?
Prendete ad esempio l'apoteosi dell'amore:
il matrimonio.
Che è già una battuta, questa.
(Risate)
30 anni fa, noi raccontavamo
del matrimonio classico.
- Cioè il trionfo della mamma:
altro che wedding planner di adesso.
-Eh sì, perché organizzava tutto lei;
e faceva fronte, anche,
a qualche piccolo imprevisto apocalittico.
- Ma adesso ragiona, mamma:
ma non vado a messa nemmeno a Natale!
Che senso ha che mi sposi in chiesa?
Che senso ha?
Non vuoi sposarti in chiesa?
No, non mi sposo in chiesa.
No? Che senso ha?
E il senso è il senso
che non semo de manco degli altri:
lo fanno tutti, te o fa anca ti!
Guarda, dovesse essere l'ultima cosa
che faccio nella mia vita,
a costo de portarte de peso,
ma ti chel giorno
ti te sposi in ciesa, va ben?
Abbiamo però raccontato
anche del matrimonio adesso.
Perché, c'è ancora gente che si sposa?
Sì.
Però magari adesso arriva il nonno,
e chiede: ma la sposa non arriva? .
- Ma sì nonno: la sposa è già qua!
- Ma se sono due uomini?
...
Hai capito che apocalisse, per il nonno?
Certo, per lui.
E per noi, invece,
quante apocalissi tecnologiche?
Quante ne abbiamo vissute
e raccontate noi in 30 anni,
noi uomini del ventesimo secolo
prestati al ventunesimo?
Che ci sentivamo dei geni,
perché padroneggiavamo
il videoregistratore
mentre i nostri genitori non capivano.
- Papà, - cossa xé 'sta roba?
- Devi schiacciare play, play,
schiacciare play per vedere.
E non capisso!
E lo dicevamo con lo stesso
tono spazientito
con il quale, adesso,
si rivolgono a noi i nostri figli:
- Papà, sei veramente un nabbo a Fortnite.
E cosa continui a schiacciare R2,
se ti ho killato?
- Mi ha killato.
A noi che al massimo giocavamo a tennis
con le due lineette e il puntino.
Bellissimo: pic, pic,
pic pic -  era stupendo.
Abbiamo raccontato dell'avvento del cd.
E dell'apocalisse,
di miliardi di musicassette.
- Che per fortuna sono state buttate via,
insieme a tutti i walkman del mondo.
Ma come per fortuna!
Ma dico: era necessario.
Io amavo il walkman!
Ancora con il Walkman? sei vecchio.
Abbiamo raccontato dell'ascesa
e della caduta delle tv private.
Dell'arrivo delle pay tv,
e poi della smart tv interattiva.
- Cosa che io non ho ancora capito, eh.
- Ma sì, dai che è facile: guarda.
Ciao, Sky! Per piacere,
mettime quel film dal titolo -
dai, quello con quell'attore -
Sì , dai, quell'attore,
quello che è sposato con quella attrice,
quella che dici che che assomigli
a quella che viene sempre
in palestra con te.
Ah, ho capito! Sì sì,
ce l'ho sulla punta della lingua!
Dai, guarda sul telefonino!
Ecco: il telefonino,
un'altra bella invenzione.
Dico io: ma non andavamo meglio tutti,
col telefono fisso?
Telefono fisso?
Ora che il mondo progredisce?
Eh, lo so. E sempre più velocemente.
E uno dice: ma devi stare
al passo coi tempi.
Ok, mi sono appena comprato l'iPhone 7.
C'è l'iPhone 18, adesso. Ma dove vivi?
E coi social?
- Vabbè, ho Facebook .
- Eh, ma c'è Instagram!
Anche Instagram? E Tik tok?
- Uno non ci sta dietro.
È WhatsApp? Bello WhatsApp!
Sì, ma c'è Telegram!
Uno ha appena imparato a usare WhatsApp,
e subito arriva Telegram.
Ma cosa serve? E la realtà virtuale?
E l'intelligenza artificiale?
E tutte le app?
E la app no, è troppo, no.
Ma vuoi stare al passo coi tempi eh?
Vuoi aggiornarti?
Vuoi entrare nel mondo
del futuro, sì o no ?
Io vorrei entrare, nel mondo del futuro;
bisogna vedere se il mondo
del futuro, ci farà entrare.
Certo, guarda qua: Meta!
Ma che è, rugby?
No: entrando in Meta,
parteciperemo ad una festa
di giovani del futuro!
Ah, sì?
E allora sì, che ti dimostrerò
cosa vuol dire rimanere giovani dentro.
Ma chi, mi e ti? Mah...
Uh!
Va che bello!
Ma cos'è sta roba?
Eh, questo è il menu delle opzioni
che puoi scegliere, no?
In orbita su Marte?
Guarda: immergiti
nel profondo degli oceani;
Operare come veri chirurghi
- chirurgi - chirurghi - chirurgi
- Chirurgi. Chirurghi.
Va be', non importa:
Posso finalmente realizzare
il sogno della mia vita:
posso fare un'operazione!
Guarda che non mi sembra il caso.
Ma sì, ma cosa sarà!
La chirurgia.
Paziente deceduto.
Ti avevo detto di non toccare niente.
Ma no gò tocà niente!
E poi, noi siamo qui per la festa!
Adesso, indossiamo due avatar da sbarbai,
due avatar da sbarbai
che così non ci riconosceranno mai.
- Ok - Vero, bro?
- Adesso io ti dico, vero bro?
Però tu devi rispondere: sì, fra!
- Ah, ok. - Vero bro? - Sì, fra.
Oh, guarda che roba! Guarda che avatar!
Adesso, dato che conosco il buttafuori,
perché li conosco tutti.
Siamo pronti?
Festa!
(Musica)
Scusa, ma - Help!
La musica non sarà troppo forte?
Ma no, i giovani ascoltano
la musica forte!
Ho capito: ma almeno un brano anni 80?
Stai zitto, vuoi che ci sgamino subito?
- Comunque, io qui
il buttafuori non lo vedo
- Eh, neanch'io. Cosa vuoi che ti dica?
- Guarda: qui c'è un campanello.
Cosa c'è scritto?
Eh non vedo: è scritto troppo piccolo.
Io suono, eh?
(Suona)
Benvenuti alla Super Festa
"Giovani Future 2078".
Grazie, grazie.
Hai visto, bro?
- Certo, frà!
- Avvicinare l'iride per la lettura
delle fibre ottiche.
Soggetto non riconosciuto:
ha anche la cataratta.
Strano, che un ragazzo
soffra di cataratta.
No, perché dovevo andarmi a operare,
poi non c'era posto, allora -
Se nel frattempo può farti entrare.
Siamo qui per la festa, siamo giovani!
Ah, penso di aver capito.
Allora adesso per entrare dovete esibire
il codice comodenotica cinque.
Eh?
Ma dove volete andare?
Per cortesia, guardate:
apprezziamo lo sforzo,
ma voi proprio non potete entrare
in questa festa per il nuovo inizio.
Andatevene!
E per voi sarà pianto,
e stridore di denti.
(Musica)
E quindi, noi ci siamo
sempre nutriti di apocalissi:
ma lo abbiamo fatto da comici.
Con il sorriso.
Cercando di far riflettere,
ma cercando anche di portare
un po' di sollievo con una risata.
Una risata nel presente,
consapevoli che il futuro
è il seme di un albero
che va piantato adesso.
E nella piena consapevolezza che,
come dice l'Apocalisse Evangelica,
"Il giorno in cui ci saranno
nuovi cieli e una nuova terra,
dove regneranno giustizia e amore,
dove non ci sarà più né malattia né morte,
i comici non avranno
più senso di esistere."
(Applausi)
Grazie!